[Music]
on this Friday night Justin Trudeau on
the record the Prime Minister defends
his government's Convoy response things
were not getting better this was the
right thing to do and we did it how his
historic testimony shapes the weeks-long
inquiry into the emergencies act
Fighting For Freedom a pair of
indigenous sisters search for justice
after nearly three decades Behind Bars
preparing Black Friday the Canadian
retailer is looking to give back on one
of the biggest shopping days of the year
and choosing love we really really feel
like we're a movement how one London
shop is using the Holiday Rush to help
refugees in need
global national with para Nasser there
is a sense that people that the police
jurisdiction had lost control and wasn't
able to control the situation
in a packed room prime minister Justin
Trudeau vigorously defended his
government's decision to use the
emergencies act during the so-called
Freedom Convoy after six weeks of
dramatic testimony he was the final and
most anticipated witness to testify
because despite the inquiry hearing from
high-ranking politicians their aides law
enforcement officials only the Prime
Minister can put his signature on the
document invoking the ACT which he did
for the first time in the 34-year
history of the law
good evening and thank you for joining
us the Prime Minister was candid in
describing his reason for enacting those
unprecedented Powers saying it came down
to a question what if he didn't our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken joins us now David a a rare moment
for his sitting PM you've covered the
inquiry extensively what was your
takeaway from his testimony well far the
Prime Minister spent more than five
hours on the stand today that's a
remarkable amount of time and he
provided new insights into his rationale
for invoking the emergencies act he
talked about the fears he had of
escalating violence and how he
personally came to justify doing what no
prime minister had ever done the key
question of course why why did prime
minister Justin Trudeau invoke the
emergencies act we could not say that
there was no potential for threats of
serious violence for serious violence to
happen over the coming days we were
seeing things escalate not things get
under control but what if he didn't sign
it what if he had waited another couple
of weeks what if the worst had happened
in those following days what if
um someone had gotten hurt the
responsibility of a prime minister is
to make the tough calls and keep people
safe
and why did he not just meet the
protesters some of whom were sitting
there meters away from him on Friday and
who had testified earlier at this same
commission that that's all they really
wanted a meeting we wanted to be heard
we wanted to have discussions but
Trudeau saw it quite differently was
clear that it wasn't
that they just wanted to be heard
they wanted to be obeyed
they wanted us to change public policy
Public Health policy designed uh to help
Canadians the commission Council
wondered if future Prime Ministers will
now find it easy to invoke the
emergencies act against anything they
might perceive as an emergency but do
you worry about the floodgates aspect of
this that having done this you've now
maybe unleashed the Kraken
um this wasn't something we were eager
to do
um and I dare say that
future governments
um
are likely to look at this experience
and say yeah no it's not really not
something we want to go through lightly
did this PM have any regrets I was very
comfortable that we were at a moment
where
this was the right thing to do
and
we did it now does the commissioner
Justice Paul Rulo agree that Trudeau did
the right thing roulet has until
February to answer that question pharah
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you David
the public inquiry provided Canadians
with an extraordinary look inside
government and police operations during
a public crisis it exposed a frenzy of
confusion and frustration amongst top
politicians and law enforcement
officials but has all the testimony
brought us any closer to understanding
whether the emergencies Act was needed
or not our Eric Sorensen looks at what
we've learned over the past six weeks
this was the moment police moved in with
Force backed for the first time in
Canadian history by the emergencies act
it ended a three-week blockade of
Parliament Hill and set off a six-week
inquiry with one central question where
those emergency Powers Justified
while the noisy occupation and the
misery of local residents played out in
public the inquiry revealed behind the
scenes dysfunction between levels of
government and police jurisdictions
Ottawa Police were unprepared for a long
standoff at one point the federal
Justice Minister texted that the city's
police chief was incompetent I was quite
frustrated I will admit there was
Municipal anger toward the provincial
Premier Doug Ford for not being engaged
even though Provincial Police were key
players it was frustrating that the
province was not as
responsive frustration that police
developed a plan but the RCMP
commissioner did not present it to
cabinet and frustration that protests
especially at the border were damaging
relations with our largest trading
partner that was a dangerous moment for
Canada I felt but were extraordinary
powers restricting civil liberties
across the country needed to subdue a
public protest I'm Canadian and I have
that Democratic rate after or six weeks
of testimony we still have not heard
anything that would justify the
invocation of the emergencies act which
is an extraordinary piece of legislation
that allows the government to create new
criminal law by executive order but top
security and intelligence officials
advise that the emergencies Act was
necessary the regular tools would just
not enough to address the situation
against the backdrop of a public crisis
and the political realities at the time
commissioner Paul rullo will have to
consider detailed legal interpretations
of the emergencies act with only weeks
to sum it all up from police governance
through intergovernmental relations to
the content of the thesis act to
disinformation to the Genesis of the
freedom Convoy it's going to be a very
tight time frame to deal with all that
meaningfully it's already evident that
the inquiry exposed a lack of
intergovernmental cooperation among
police and politicians suggesting a
better coordinated response could
resolve a similar crisis before the
emergencies Act is contemplated next
time
Eric Sorensen Global News
it is very unusual for a sitting prime
minister to publicly take the stand like
Trudeau did today only two others have
before him John a McDonald in 1873 and
Paul Martin in 2005 for very different
reasons McDonnell testified at a royal
commission looking into government
contracts and if they were awarded in
exchange for campaign financing and you
might remember Martin was questioned in
the Gomery inquiry over concerns about a
misappropriation of government funds
good news for parents with sick children
the federal health Minister says the
emergency import of 1 million kids pain
relievers are now hitting Pharmacy
shelves
in other places it might take an
additional day or so but we'll expect
that in the next week uh you know the
the availability of those doses will be
quite clear
reports are expected in the next three
weeks domestic production has also
ramped up with more than a million
children's Advil products manufactured
by Canadian companies this month alone
that news comes as the flu is spreading
more quickly than in years past
especially among kids that's fueling
concerns because ERS and icus are
getting packed Children's Hospitals have
started canceling surgeries but as
Heather York's West explains the Alberta
Government won't allow Mass mandates in
school or let classes Move online
for families with school-aged kids it's
been a difficult fall we've been sick
basically for three months since we've
been back into school with viral
illnesses like covet RSV and the flu
surging schools are seeing student
absence levels rise staff are getting
sick too but no matter how bad it gets
Alberta schools will no longer be able
to move online Alberta's education
Minister announced Thursday schools must
ensure quote access to in-person
learning even when high numbers of
students and staff are sick also saying
students cannot be denied in-person
learning due to their decision to wear
or not wear a mask that's a recognition
that we've been asking for and school
divisions across this province have been
asking for is that Health decisions need
to be made by Health officials the virus
appears to have arrived several weeks
earlier than a normal flu season and the
growth rate or the number of cases
increasing per week is again on a scale
we really haven't seen in in recent
memory and with Children's Hospitals
already Under Pressure this infectious
diseases researcher believes Public
Health measures will be necessary at
some point soon whether those measures
take place in schools or someplace else
it's a tough one because I know if I
have a four-year-old and if my kid had
immune system problems
I would probably be one of those
hypersensitive parents just a little bit
uh worrying especially that kids are
getting so sick and uh masks are kind of
our only
Surefire way to protect what little
space we have especially in the
classroom even without mandates Health
officials are encouraging mask use again
urging everyone to get the covid and flu
vaccines to this flu season may not Peak
until early next year Heather your ex
West Global News Calgary
in Saskatchewan there's renewed
attention on the story of two Soto
sisters from the kisaku's First Nation
who have been jailed for nearly 30 years
next month they're going to learn if
they'll be granted bail while a federal
review determines if a miscarriage of
Justice landed them there in the first
place our new correspondent Melissa
origin explains
you nervous no on the steps of
Courthouse a Bittersweet reunion for
ordelia and nurisa cusons together for
the first time in 20 years I know when
she leaves I know it's gonna kick in and
I'm gonna cry
because we have to leave again we're
both strong and not mine
but you know it's hard you know we I'm
pretty sure everybody goes through this
we we're we're happy here on the outside
but inside we're hurting it was um
surreal it was emotional when I was
sitting there with her in a courtroom
now we're much older like I was 18. now
I'm 48.
my sister was 20 now she's going to be
51 so it's
you know we're getting older but we're
still being strong despite being apart
from each other this is the same
Courthouse where in 1994 they were
sentenced to life in prison for a crime
their cousin admitted to in a story by
aptn news that helped get them here
today I said I wasn't there and stuff
like that you know the second time I
said I was I was there but I left before
everything happened
in the third time I said I pretty fast
not what I did
when the kid you're scared and stuff
like that either worried and what's
going to happen and you think they
should be free yeah I think so I I I
know so the sisters were barely adults
in 1993 with their 14 year old cousin
drinking with 70 year old Anthony Joseph
Dolph at his farm near campsack
Saskatchewan they say when Dolph
propositioned them the party ended as
did his life beaten to death admitting
to the crime in court their cousin was
out of jail in two years the sisters who
denied taking part received life
sentences the case caught the attention
of Innocence Canada which is providing
free legal fees for the Sisters Senator
Kim Pate says that they are victims of a
justice system that stacked against
indigenous women Canada's most famous
exonerie David Milgard he advocated for
the women just before he passed away
earlier this year Federal Justice
Minister David lametti says that their
case requires a federal review while
that's ongoing they want to be free as
it could take years but Saskatchewan
prosecutors say they will argue against
that next month mind and they don't want
media they're reporting on it a judge
will rule on the publication ban next
week prosecutors argue reports could
taint a jury pool if there's a new trial
the sisters time together in court was
too short but they thanked media who've
kept the story in the spotlight to get
awareness out there that
women in prison we need help like
there's a lot of injustices still
Melissa Ridgid Global News Winnipeg
a new tool in the fight against
suspected online Predators coming up an
all-access look at the new technology
helping investigators in Alberta
foreign
it's been called an epidemic and law
enforcement agencies know they can't
fight it alone the number of online
Predators targeting Canadian youth is
increasing and so is the amount of child
sexual exploitation material often there
are not enough regulations or resources
to make a dent for the new reality
Dallas Flex hog takes us to the front
lines with a specialized police team in
Alberta that has a high-tech tool
critical for catching predators
it's early morning in Calgary and police
are moving in on a suspect's home
City police Open Door
hi good morning
this search is part of an investigation
involving suspected online child sexual
abuse material the Southern Alberta
internet child exploitation unit or ice
has been working on this case for more
than a year when I started in 2013 I
don't even think we'd hit 400 cases for
the whole year and this year we will
probably hit close to 1500 cases ice has
a high-tech tool a mobile evidence
recovery lab called Myrtle for short
Global News got rare access inside not
all ice humans can afford to have a
mobile forensic unit so we're Super
Lucky super grateful it is life-altering
for how we do business that's because
officers can seize items and bring them
here for the text to review immediately
traditionally before exhibits had to
come back to the office and get
subjected to a full forensic analysis
which is time so with Myrtle we can
typically drill them down to okay we
only need three of those items because
the rest have no evidentiary value over
the course of the next few few hours
exhibits arrive and the forensic
examiners go through it all meticulously
after hours of searching and analyzing
one says they found some disturbing
videos
that's enough for me right now the
suspect is now facing five charges it's
too soon to tell what the outcome will
be as the allegations will need to be
tested in court investigators know this
problem is Insidious and pervasive and
it's why ice gave us access to their
operations to show how this tool can be
vital in Catching child Predators
knowing that you can only just scratch
the surface of what's going on that to
me is the toughest part of of my job I
think that's the fear of everybody in
this unit is missing a child that's
being abused at the end of the day the
victims of the crime are the most
vulnerable in our society Dallas flexaw
Global News
and you can watch Dallas's full report
on the new reality Saturday at 7 5 p.m
Pacific right here on global
[Music]
Black Friday mindfulness ahead retailers
looking to make a difference on the
busiest shopping day of the year
Black Friday is here
these Shoppers lined up in the cold in
Toronto the retail Council of Canada
says on average people are planning to
spend nearly 800 over the holidays but
as Ann gaviola explains many retailers
are inviting people to rethink rampant
consumerism
a typical Black Friday scene long
lineups outside big box stores chaos and
malls people hunting for the ultimate
deals consumerism on steroids payments
processor maneris predicts Black Friday
spending volumes will be up nearly 10
percent this year compared with 2021.
the idea of pushing product and sales
and discounts on people isn't something
that resonates with us as a brand some
retailers are taking a different
approach though edmonton-based poppy
barley is inviting customers to use
their dollars to make a difference
rather than slashing prices instead we
donate all proceeds from our sales up to
twenty thousand dollars to a
not-for-profit indigenous owned slow
fashion women's wear Boutique and Muller
in Winnipeg isn't offering discounts
either the owner of the Canadian made
brand which has been around for 18 years
is encouraging mindful rather than
mindless purchases the to actually stick
with our core values of buying better by
buying less and we are offering uh free
alterations for life on the pieces that
you purchase pandemic restrictions were
a windfall for large retailers but dealt
a huge financial blow to smaller
businesses Rising labor costs inflation
supply chain snarls and climbing
interest rates mean many are still
struggling I
small businesses and 99 of them are in
the make or break area right now they're
not even sure if they can make it
through because it's just been so hard
Black Friday is traditionally the
busiest day in Canada in terms of total
transactions and dollars spent there's
so much pressure on us to slash prices
and compete with the big box shops and
we just we just can't we can't do that
small businesses say it's more important
than ever to vote with your dollars and
gaviola Global News Toronto gifts with
heart next in London charity hoping
Shoppers will choose love this holiday
season
[Music]
if you're someone who loves giving gifts
but feel the people in your life don't
need more stuff there's a unique shop
run by a charity and it's hoping you'll
Choose Love instead Europe you're a
chief Crystal commencing explains
it might look like your average holiday
pop-up store
[Music]
but this one in London's famous Soho
district is different it presents
Shoppers with Alternatives it's a shop
you don't leave with anything
but you I suppose you leave with a good
feeling Instead at Choose Love Shoppers
pick gifts for people in need
warm clothes for those trying to survive
formidable conditions in Ukraine food
and water for children in Afghanistan
where rates of illness and malnutrition
are rising even life-saving supports for
those risking it all trying to get to
Europe in hopes of claiming Asylum we
really really feel like we're a movement
of people who all choose love we will do
what we can to support each other more
than 250 groups working in 26 countries
are supported by Shoppers who put
compassion in their carts online or in
person and I want to help everyone
if I had money I would give the lot away
many tears end up on the floor as staff
explain how people have been helped over
the past six years Shoppers can give in
their name or someone else's and they
can pick up a little something to put
under the tree I'm here as a tourist so
uh
[Music]
a host of celebrity endorsements are
helping to boost sales which will
continue right up until Christmas
[Music]
the retail spaces are gifted to the
uk-based charity and sponsors help cover
operating costs with the holiday
shopping season in full swing the hope
is that the physical store will be a
window of opportunity for people to give
back Crystal gemancing Global News
London
and that's global national for this
Friday I'm Farah Nasser and on behalf of
our whole crew I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's your Canada is Glen
Mill Pond in Corner Brook Newfoundland
and Labrador we love seeing your Canada
so please keep emailing us those photos
to viewers at globalnational.com until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other good night
[Music]
thank you